thanks to the box-office success of
jigsaw it looks like we'll be getting a
9th Saw movie in the next couple of
years I think the filmmakers counted on
this happening because they seem to have
left little clues like this one to set
up the next installment before we get
started I know what you people are gonna
say Oh Hoffman could still be alive
Bobby dagen could be a disciple of
jigsaw blah blah blah and to that I say
Hoffman is dead okay he's chained to the
same spot that Adam was in the original
song we all know there's only one way
out of that and Gordon
clearly throws away the key as for the
others I'll do a full rundown of who I
think might be alive and possibly
reappearing in song 9 but honestly I
don't see anyone from the original seven
movies making a return I mean what was
the point of jigsaw if not to freshen
things up and bring the franchise back
to theaters we got all new characters
and I don't think any of the other
sequels had a total of 0 flashbacks to
other movies even the title breaking the
numeric sequence of saw films just tells
me this is supposed to be a fresh slate
in a way it wasn't my favorite saw film
by any means but I do admire the way it
revived the property without relying on
a reboot to wipe away the glorious
continuity that's been established and I
think it did a great job of laying the
foundations for saw 9 so that's exactly
where I'll start the big question going
into the new movie is who's gonna be the
next jigsaw in the last movie we saw
Logan Nelson replicating jigsaws
teachings at first it would appear that
Nelson is a corrupt jigsaw because he
liked Hoffman uses the jigsaw image for
personal vendetta and selfish reasons
however in the final moments Nelson
reveals that everyone he puts in the
game deserved to be there under John
Kramer's ideals he mentions that the
first three people in his game were
criminals that got off the hook that
were similar to the players in jigsaws
original game remember the game we saw
in the movie was John Kramer's game from
ten years ago
we only actually see little glimpses of
Nelson's game and the victims the last
two players were Halloran and Nelson
Halloran deserves to be there because
he's the one who took bribes and got
those criminals off the hook including
the murderer of Nelson's wife and then
there's Nelson himself who switched the
labels on John Kramer's brain scan and
never
punished for it he never woke up from
John Kramer's sedative in time to play
the game in which he was originally
supposed to be tested so he put himself
in his own game in order to test himself
and see if he was as talented as jigsaw
this also replicates John putting
himself in the room in the original saw
everything seems to add up towards him
being the perfect successor to jigsaw
some might argue that Nelson can't
really continue being jigsaw in a future
movie but I think there's evidence that
he can unlike John Kramer who tends to
leave the corpses in secret locations
Nelson moves his to be discovered by the
public but he doesn't have to do that
for detective Halloran Logan set things
up in a way to make everyone think that
Halloran is the new jigsaw in fact the
only part he seems to care about from
the audio admission is this so if
Halloran were to disappear right now
everyone would think that he is
responsible allowing Logan to continue
the work of jigsaw with new games in the
future but he makes one mistake John
Kramer tells him to never allow personal
anger and revenge to interfere but as
far as I can tell there's one
participant who never gets a fair chance
at redemption
and that is Edgar Munson the man who
murdered Nelson's wife he seems to be
involved in another game set up by
Nelson and despite appearing to succeed
Nelson shoots him takes him off life
support and dumps him and John Kramer's
grave the original jigsaw never actually
murdered anyone but Nelson makes this
mistake to avenge his wife he may have
faltered off the path John Kramer set
for him
due to the PTSD he picked up in the army
which you can read about by pausing here
in the movie we've already seen what
happens when one of jigsaws successors
breaks the rules the disciples of jigsaw
come after him to make things right even
if it's not mentioned in Psalm 9 you can
bet a showdown between Logan Nelson and
the disciples of jigsaw is coming in the
future so who's going to be a part of
this battle we know dr. Lawrence Gordon
has played his part in the past and he's
someone who's definitely still alive and
active
I've speculated on who some of these
other pig masks who helped dr. Gordon
could be some of you in the comments of
the previous videos that they
could be minor characters from the saw
seven opening based on some producers
commentary track I'm gonna go ahead and
say that's not canon and if that was the
intention at one time it's gonna be
changed now that they're continuing the
series I speculated that Nelson may
actually be one of Gordon's assistants
but there are a couple of other
possibilities as well this is where the
characters from the previous films could
come in it would make sense that Gordon
would work with any of the other members
of the jigsaw survivor group from saw
seven but there are other survivors who
weren't seen in that group for example
Brent and Terra Abbott from saw six the
father of that family was the guy who's
denied insurance coverage needed to
survive so it makes sense that his
family would want to see justice served
I could see Brent now a fully grown
adult being a powerful force in a new
movie another character who would be a
grown-up now
is Daniel Matthews the son of the
detective from saw to he was also a
survivor it would be easy to see him
learning under John Kramer's wing after
losing his father then we've got Corbett
denlon a survivor who lost both of her
parents and saw three because Kramer was
already gone she would have had to have
been trained by the corrupt mark Hoffman
meaning that if she does end up
appearing again she might actually be
more on Nelson side then there's Pamela
Jenkins the reporter who sensationalized
jigsaw stories for her own personal gain
she'd be another candidate to be on
Nelson's side because she may have been
corrupted by Hoffman by the way Nelson
does have anonymous people helping him -
it could be cool in a future movie to
see - jig songs and their followers
engaged in a war of ideals but like I
said before I think it's unlikely we'll
see the return of old characters because
the new jigsaw film sets up the
possibility for new pig mask minions
Eleanor is an obvious candidate due to
her fandom for jigsaw and the fact that
Nelson is grooming her throughout the
movie the last we see of her in jigsaw
shows her getting picked up after
escaping the pig farm and she's got a
look of fear on her face so maybe
someone from the survivor group
plans for her there's also the fan site
she spends all that time on jigsaw rules
which could offer a new pool of
candidates to be assistants Nelson will
need the extra help because there plenty
more criminals set free
during the Halloran regime and there
could be other corrupt officials as well
if you're still not convinced that
there's gonna be another one let me
direct your attention to the news
clippings in Eleanor's studio this
article from the soft five era says the
story will be continued on 6 7 8 & 9 if
that's not enough proof for you then
look at this story which is supposedly
about jigsaw but the contents of the
article seem to only talk about
Ticketmaster they want us to buy tickets
to jigsaw so they can make saw 9 so if
you bought tickets to jigsaw or if
you're excited about the revival of the
franchise let me know by leaving a like
on this video and leave your ideas for
the next song in the comments and if
there are enough cool ones maybe I'll
feature them in a future video and if
you haven't already yet remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week wring that death
spell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one
assuming we both survive